Are you bored with where you work?
There’s no shame in it, a lot of people
are.
Or maybe you hit a run of bad luck recently,
and you got furloughed or let go from your
old job.
It’s a stressful time, and you’re probably
asking: What type of career would be right
for me?
Maybe you want some excitement - like chasing
down escaped monsters from high-security containment
facilities.
Maybe you want something a little more intellectually
engaging - like joining some of the world’s
finest minds in finding the answers to mysterious
ancient secrets.
Or maybe you’re the ambitious type - Someone
with plenty of hashtag Hustle.
Perhaps nothing would satisfy you more than
climbing to the very top of the corporate
ladder, into a position that would make you
one of the most powerful human beings on the
planet.
If any or even all of these sound like they
describe you, then maybe your perfect career
would be working for The SCP Foundation - an
incredibly powerful, top secret organization
devoted to securing, containing, and protecting
the supernatural across the globe and beyond.
You could be one of the thousands of little
turning cogs that keeps this organization
running, and keeps the world safe from supernatural
threats.
But you can’t even get into your local country
club.
How can you find your way into one of the
most elite groups in history?
Well, we can’t pretend it’ll be easy,
but it’s definitely not impossible - today,
we’re going to give you a primer on the
potential ways you could join the proud ranks
of the SCP Foundation.
With help from files and evidence across the
Foundation database, we’ve figured out many
of the different positions available at the
SCP Foundation, and what actions and qualifications
you may need to make the cut.
Though we can’t promise you won’t be terminated,
vaporized, eaten, or sent to a terrifying
pocket dimension in the process.
First, it’s vital to know exactly what you’re
applying for.
The SCP Foundation is a complex group, but
thankfully for us, it does have a command
structure that’s pretty easy to understand.
This will help us figure out the positions
on offer, so you can update your LinkedIn
profile accordingly.
There are two main categories of jobs at play
here: We have Security Clearance Categories,
which range from zero to five, and we have
Personnel Classifications, which run from
A-Class to E-Class.
Let us break it down for you: Level 0 Security
Clearance covers jobs like logistics and janitorial
services.
They’re the lowest entry level of any Foundation
jobs, and you’ll basically be told nothing.
You might as well be cleaning the bathrooms
at a local gym.
Level 1 covers most of the same jobs as Level
0, except these staff members perform their
jobs in closer proximity to anomalies - so
you’ll still be cleaning bathrooms, but
at greater risk to your life.
Level 2 is the most common level of Clearance,
and covers most of the jobs you can apply
for at the Foundation.
Junior researchers, field operatives, containment
specialists.
You have a decent grasp on the strangeness
of your profession, but you’re still locked
out of the major secrets.
Level 3 is a step up, and covers most senior
research staff, project managers, security
officers, response team members, and Mobile
Task Force operatives - all of which we’ll
discuss more later.
Level 4 is Top Secret, and reserved only for
senior administrative positions, like Site
Directors, Security Directors, or Mobile Task
Force Commanders.
Finally, Level 5 - which gives access to every
secret the Foundation holds and more.
This is reserved largely for the O5 Council
and those working directly under them.
We’re not saying it’s necessarily impossible
for you to get into one of those thirteen
seats of ultimate power, but it’s probably
impossible.
The A through E personnel classes are a little
easier to process - the further along your
letter is in the alphabet, the more dangerous
your job, because you work in closer proximity
to anomalies.
A-Class staff are considered critical to the
running of the Foundation, like the O5 Council,
so they’re usually not even allowed near
an anomaly.
D-Class, as you probably already know, are
guinea pigs regularly thrown into the clutches
of anomalies to see what happens.
The only thing worse is E-Class: Which applies
to agents who are already under the active
effects of anomalies, and thus, are quarantined.
Now that you fully understand the command
structure of the SCP Foundation, we can talk
about specific roles, and what it may take
to find these various job titles attached
to your name.
We’ll start with the lowest of the low,
and work our way up to the top of the pyramid.
Starting, of course, with D-Class.
The upside of D-Class is that you don’t
really need any kind of qualifications to
join - the majority of D-Class personnel are
death row inmates, so if you commit a few
capital offenses and get yourself caught,
you’ll likely be up for consideration.
After all, employee turnaround for D-Class
is pretty crazy, for obvious reasons.
The downside is that you really, really, really
don’t want to become a D-Class.
While there are some rare examples of the
lives of D-Classes being improved - like one
who was released to pursue a law degree after
being educated by SCP-5094 - it’s largely
a literally dead end job.
But let’s say you’re a little luckier
than that and the job you seek, while still
dangerous, will at least get you a decent
pension and dental coverage.
We’re talking about the day to day, bread
and butter jobs that keep the whole Foundation
running: Site Staff.
If you’re working on site at any of the
hundreds or even thousands of secure areas
the Foundation maintains across the globe,
you have four different possible career paths:
Containment Specialist, Researcher, Security
Officer, and Tactical Response Officer.
Containment specialists are, as you can probably
tell from the name, experts in maintaining
containment for anomalies.
This career path forks into two possible branches.
In the more active of the two branches, Containment
Specialists enter zones of active, anomalous
activity, and contain the anomaly for transport
back to the nearest operational site.
To join this career path, you’d likely be
expected to come from a military background
due to the risky and tactical nature of the
job.
The second branch is a little less hands on.
These are the actual engineers and technicians
who work with researchers to devise the containment
procedures for the various SCPs.
For this role, you’ll not only need to likely
understand physics and engineering at an expert
level, you’ll also need an extraordinarily
creative mind.
You need to think outside the box to keep
the anomalies in the box.
A recurring theme you’ll find when it comes
to Foundation jobs is that you don’t seek
out the Foundation for a job, if you’re
the right person and show potential, they’ll
find you.
Researchers are a similar story.
These are the best research scientists in
the world, scouted by the Foundation to assist
the cause.
If you’re someone with a true passion for
science - with topics including, but not limited
to, biology, physics, chemistry, botany, and
xenobiology - and you’re willing to put
in the work to reach the very top of your
field, the Foundation may just come knocking
at your door.
Much like a lot of prestigious universities,
the Foundation also sometimes considers legacy
candidates.
The famous Dr. Bright, for example, became
a member of the Foundation’s research corps
because his mother and father worked for the
Foundation, and it didn’t hurt that several
of his siblings were anomalous too.
Next, Security Officers, more informally known
as Guards.
This job is worth applying for the paycheck
alone as there’s likely some good hazard
pay attached to it.
Most Security Officers perform physical guard
duties and are recruited from law enforcement,
the corrections industry, and the military.
However, the other half of the Security Officers
work in information security and, as a result,
are chosen for their IT prowess and their
backgrounds in the intelligence community.
And finally, as far as Site Staff are concerned,
we have Tactical Response Officers.
Don’t expect to get this job if your background
is civilian though since these special operatives
are the first line of defense between Foundation
sites and external threats, from anomalous
attackers to hostile groups of interest trying
to infiltrate.
If you want this job, you really need to put
in the hours, days, months, and years rising
through the ranks in the military.
If you do get the job though, you’ll likely
be stationed at one of the larger and more
important sites to remain on constant guard
for any potential threats.
But let’s say you don’t want to work on
a containment site.
Maybe you want to travel, see the world, get
a little excitement.
Thankfully, there are two different career
paths that allow you to do just that - Field
Agents and Mobile Task Force members.
The Field Agent position is one of the more
accessible in the Foundation, largely because
of the fact there are so many ways in.
If you’re an exceptionally observant and
discrete person, this job is probably for
you seeing as it’s essentially being a spy
for the Foundation.
You may be offered the job if you work in
law enforcement, the government, or any kind
of emergency service.
These undercover agents also infiltrate groups
of interest or secret societies the Foundation
wishes to keep an eye on, like the Serpent’s
Hand or the Children of the Scarlet King.
If you’re in any of these positions, or
already work as a field agent for the mainstream
intelligence community, becoming a Foundation
Field Agent may be your calling.
Mobile Task Forces are a little more extreme.
They’re made up of elite operatives drawn
from all over the Foundation, often with a
heavy emphasis on military experience.
The more specialized you are, the more likely
you are to land a spot on one of these teams.
Are you an expert in explosives?
Try for MTF Epsilon-9, the "Fire Eaters.”
Are you an expert in epidemiology and biohazard
containment?
Join MTF Beta-7, dubbed the "Maz Hatters.”
Are you a benevolent anomaly aligned with
the interests of the Foundation?
MTF Alpha-9, aka "Last Hope” is just for
you!
The Foundation sometimes even recruits ex-members
of enemy groups of interest into MTFs on occasion.
Of course, despite there being plenty of ways
into this profession, none of them are easy,
and the job carries huge risks due to how
often MTFs see combat.
What if you’ve always been more of a leader
than a follower though?
You’re a natural manager, someone who has
all their anomalous ducks in a row.
Perhaps you’re eyeing the role of Site Director,
the one who all other department heads on
site report directly to.
How do you get your foot in the door?
It’s simple.
Site Directors start off working some other
job for the Foundation, like researcher or
Security Officer, and simply climb through
the ranks until they reach the most senior
position in the site where they work.
Oftentimes, Site Directors were previously
very committed researchers, like Dr. Bright
or Dr. Gears.
And finally, the biggest question of all:
How does one become a member of the legendary
O5 Council?
Due to the extremely mysterious nature of
the Council, this one is hard to say.
Exact information about each member and their
past is shrouded in secrecy, but it stands
to reason that any new members are elected
in by a majority of the pre-existing council
members on the board.
Like Dr. Bright’s father, Adam Bright, it
is theoretically possible to work your butt
off and get onto the O5 Council through decades
of pure grit, but you’re probably wasting
your time.
The Council works in mysterious ways after
all...
If we’ve learned anything today, it’s
that any job actually worth having at the
SCP Foundation isn’t gotten easily.
But hey, considering the SCP Foundation has
its shadowy fingers in every pie, and its
thousands of factions worldwide are masked
by just as many public-facing front businesses,
for all you know, you might be working for
the Foundation already.
Now go watch “SCP - 5545 - Mysterious Tunnels
In Antarctica - ABNORMALITY” and “SCP
- 5000 - Why?
The Full Story Compilation” to unlock more
secrets from the world of the SCP Foundation.